practice faithful persistence means
never ever ever give up I mean how many
of you have ever had a great idea talked
about it thought about it didn't do it
then someone else did it was successful
when you went darn I should have done
that you know one of the greatest myths
that's pervasive in our culture today is
that you're entitled to a great life if
you're not experiencing joy as you think
about doing something and as you pursue
doing it then it's off course for you
he's an American author motivational
speaker corporate trainer and
entrepreneur he's the co-author of the
Chicken Soup for the Soul series that
has sold over five hundred million
copies in 40 languages in 2005 he
co-authored the success principles how
to get from where you are to where you
want to be his Jack Canfield and here's
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
I'm curious to find out which one you
guys like the best also as you're
watching the video if you hear something
that Jack says it really resonates with
you add it to the comments with quotes
so we can keep track of what you find
most relevant practice faithful
persistence means never ever ever give
up Chicken Soup for the Soul was
rejected by a hundred and forty four
publishers 144 publisher said we don't
want to publish a collection of short
stories the title stupid Chicken Soup
for the Soul what does that mean people
don't buy collections of short stories
there's never been you know successful
chain of doing that so literally we
spent 14 months trying to find a
publisher and we'd go to New York with
our agent and eventually our agent gave
us the book back and said I can't sell
this so we went to the National
booksellers Association convention down
in Anaheim
we went from booth to booth to booth for
three days and there were 4,000
publishers represented there and we go
would you publish a book would you
publish a book would you publish my book
and we got no no no no no it was late on
the third day that a little publisher
from Florida after we'd gotten over 144
rejections said we'll read it and then
they said we said well how many copies
do you think we'll sell after they said
yeah we'll buy it a couple weeks later
said we'll publish it and we said well
maybe 20,000 if we're lucky now we said
we our goal is to sell a million and a
half in a year and a half
now have you ever told someone your
dream and had them laugh out loud of you
he laughs out loud now if we had given
up after a hundred publishers had said
no I wouldn't be standing here today
you know wouldn't have happened and so
you've got to be willing to persevere
because we didn't take no see when the
world says no you say next let's
practice that if I say no you say
absolutely there's only five or six
billion people out there you can go and
ask right there's over four thousand
publishers just here in the state of
California so what we have is this
endless possibility but you have to
persevere it's as if the universe tests
our commitment and so today we have a
hundred and forty seven titles in print
we sold over 115 million copies
we're in 47 languages and over a billion
dollars where the Chicken Soup for the
Soul books have been sold worldwide so
if you're willing to decide what you
want believe it's possible consciously
envision the future feel the feelings of
what it would feel like if you would
achieve this goal you could have
anything and then you take action both
obvious actions and inspired actions you
can do anything one of the the functions
of belief is taking action we did a
survey of about 2,000 top entrepreneurs
and we noticed that one of the things
that people who win in that world have
is a bias for action if they have an
inspiration they act on it I mean how
many of you have ever had a great idea
talked about it thought about it didn't
do it then someone else did it was
successful when you went darn I should
have done that maybe it was buy that
piece of property and as all that we all
have that piece of property we wish we'd
bought you know anyway so we're going to
be looking at the idea that taking
action is part of Law of Attraction see
a lot of people thinking just sit in
your room
meditate visualize having the perfect
car the perfect house the perfect
relationship and then it'll kind of just
come to you and I always say unless you
live at the bottom of the hill
whereas a road it's probably not going
to be a Cadillac show up in your living
room right so think about this the last
six letters of the word attractions fell
what AC tion action now there's two
kinds of actions that are critical
there's obvious actions if you want a
certain kind of car you should go down
and test drive it you should find out
how much it costs you should see what it
costs to maintain it you should go you
know spend I like the test-drive a car
three or four times go down to the
dealer take a camera stick my head out
the window say take a picture of me I'll
be back to buy it put it up on my
refrigerator look at it every day
eventually you know those kind of things
produce car right saving for it and so
forth but there are also things called
inspired actions all of a sudden you get
an inspiration to do something and you
didn't know what it was you don't have a
sense of like how's this rationally
going to make sense for me to move
forward in my life I'll give you an
example a friend of mine dr. Ignatius
Piazza graduates chiropractic school he
wants to move to Monterey
near Pebble Beach where the golf course
is and he gets there and he says to the
local Chiropractic Association like to
join you and like you to help me get my
practice started and they said we don't
need anymore chiropractors we have one
chiropractor for every eight people in
this area as too many now he could have
said okay let the external reality
control his internal experience but he
doesn't do that he said I'm going to
think about this and visualize it and
believe in it and something will come
that I will do and what came to him to
do was to take six months before he
opened his office and put a pin where he
wanted his office and then concentric
circles knock on every door in every
neighborhood saying hi I'm a new doctor
in town could I ask you a few questions
you know I'm starting this practice
should I open from 5:00 told 9:00 in the
morning and or should I be open from
5:00 until 9:00 at night for people who
have nine-to-five jobs which would be
better should I advertise in this paper
or that paper should I call it Ignatius
Piazza chiropractic or chiropractic West
then his last question was the fire of
an open house would you like to receive
an invitation they said yes he wrote it
though now over six months he knocked on
12500 doors talked to 6500 people and
gathered over 4,000 names of people who
said yes I'd like an invitation you're
open
now when he opened his office six months
later in a town that did not need
another chiropractor according to the
professionals
his first month in practice he netted
seventy two thousand dollars in his
first year in practice his gross income
was over $1,000,000 I was giving a talk
to mention this story just about five
years ago and this happened about 25
years ago someone said he knocked on my
door and he left his card and two years
later I needed the chiropractor and I
called him because we work with people
we know we've had an experience with
right so he trusted his intuition he
took action on it other people would say
oh yes I can't have what I want you got
to be willing to take the action if
you're going to be successful in
creating the life of your dreams you'd
have to believe that you are capable of
making it happen you have to believe
that you have the right stuff and that
you're able to pull it off now whether
you call it self esteem self confidence
or self assurance
it's a deep-seated belief that you have
what it takes the abilities the inner
resources the talents and the skills to
create your desired results now
believing in yourself is simply an
attitude believing yourself is a choice
you have to choose to believe that you
can do anything you set your mind to
anything at all because in fact you can
it might help you to know that the
latest brain research now indicates with
enough positive self-talk and positive
visualization combined with proper
training coaching and practice anyone
can learn to do almost anything now I've
interviewed thousands of successful
people and almost every one of them has
told me I was not the most gifted or the
most talented person in my field but I
chose to believe that anything was
possible and because of that I studied I
practiced and I worked harder than the
others and that's how I got to where I
am
you know Ruben Gonzalez a 20 year old
living in Texas hot Texas can pick up
the ludes which is a winter sport and
become an Olympic athlete if Bill Gates
who is a college dropout can become a
multi billionaire and Stephen Jay candle
who was a dyslexic student who failed
three grades in school
Oh can become a best-selling author and
the television producer then you too can
accomplish anything if you'll simply
believe it's possible so make the
decision right now to believe that you
create all of your experiences because
you do let's start creating the ones you
want by believing you can sounds a
little strange but accepting this level
of responsibility is uniquely and
inevitably empowering it means you can
do change and become anything at all you
may think that something as small as
being optimistic won't change much about
your life have you ever heard this line
just because I'm paranoid doesn't mean
the world is not to get me now that may
be a joke but many people believe the
deck is stacked against them people who
are reverse paranoids otherwise known as
optimists use the same consistent
thinking but they believe that the world
is plotting to do them good everything
that happens is pushing them in the
right direction
this attitude breeds more good thoughts
so why not practice to become a reverse
paranoid start seeing obstacles as
opportunities to grow and change when
your presentation doesn't get the sale
see it as an opportunity to create a
better presentation and become better at
your job see the task that gives you
some power to change rather than the
failure that makes you feel powerless
look for the seed of something better
when everything is going wrong almost
everyone sees getting laid off is a bad
thing but even if you want your job to
be over the end always feel sad not
inspiring the end of one job however
always holds the promise of the new
beginning of the next job if you look at
it that way you're focusing on what a
reverse paranoid thinks about identify
the great benefit in every event soon
you'll start to see that good is not an
accident but something you create with
your attitudes walk through your home
your business your apartment your condo
anything you're in charge of and make a
list of all the things that aren't
exactly the way you want it there's
never a stapler by the Xerox machine
someone always leaves that cabinet open
my kid never picks up after himself
those pictures are always slander they
never stay straight the screen door
slams there's a hole in the window you
know whatever it is write it down and
then go back and here's the key part
remember in law of attraction we always
focus on what you
what not what you don't want you don't
want to be going I don't want a man of
smokes I don't want a man who watches TV
all weekend I don't want a man who yeah
because that's what you're going to get
alright because what you focus on is
what your track so you want to focus on
the opposite so what you want to focus
on is the opposite of your irritation
list there'll be always be a stapler by
the source machine we solved it in our
office with a little chain and some glue
it doesn't leak okay but the key is
there's always solutions the pictures
that won't stay straight velcro right
through the wall
on the bottom it works you know but the
point is you want to get a list of
what's the outcome you want and then
take a day hire person or hot you know
bring a friend over and go through the
list and get as many done as you can you
know all the easy ones build some
momentum clean the garage develop a new
filing system that might be something
you know set off to another weekend and
we say all the big ones that are really
big do one a quarter every three months
solve one of those now you're getting
rid of all the stuff in your life and
why is this important we're talking
mostly about being wealthy having great
relationships great health world peace
ending hunger and you're talking about
the screen door when you don't fix the
screen door you settle and when you
settle consistently you develop a habit
of settling for what you don't want and
most people go through life in
resignation
they've resigned themselves to not
having it the way they want it it's
taken no less than 100% responsibility
for your life you're one of the greatest
myths that's pervasive in our culture
today is that you're entitled to a great
life and then somehow somewhere someone
is responsible for filling our lives
with continual happiness and exciting
career options a nurturing family and
blissful personal relationships simply
because we exist but the real truth is
that there's only one person responsible
for the quality of your life and that
person is you you see everything about
you is a result of your doing or not
doing your income your debt your
relationships your health your fitness
level your attitudes and behaviors
everything that person you see when you
look in the mirror is the chief
architect in your life you know I think
everybody knows this in their heart of
hearts but the my
can play games tricking us into thinking
that there are external factors that are
the source of our failures our
disappointments and our unhappiness but
the truth of the matter is that external
factors don't determine how you live you
and only you are in complete control of
the quality of your life experience
successful people take full
responsibility for the thoughts they
think the images they visualize in the
actions they take they don't waste their
time and energy on blaming and
complaining they evaluate their
experiences and decide if they need to
change them or not they face the
uncomfortable and they take risks in
order to create the life that they want
to live how many of you have ever
complained in your life yeah you know
here's what I've learned about
complaining in order to complain I have
to have a reference point of something
better that I want that I'm not willing
to risk creating now let me explain that
again I have to have a reference point
in my mind of something I want it's
better than what I have that I'm not
willing to risk creating so what I do is
complain about it instead see if I was
complaining about my wife it would mean
that I would have to believe that
somewhere out there in the world there's
a better woman than my wife see if every
woman on a planet died except my wife do
you think I go to work the next day and
complain about her no she's the only one
and I'd be going hey I got her this is
really cool right
do you ever hear anyone complain about
gravity very rarely you know gravity
makes us all bend over do you ever see
an old person walking down a streak on
gravity they have a little Walker
I hate gravity don't work for gravity I
wouldn't be all bent over like this
gravity sucks
now have you ever heard an older person
doing it no the reason they don't
complain about gravity is because
there's no alternative to it you know
gravity just is so if someone's
complaining about something it means
they know there's something they can do
about it because we don't complain about
the things we can't change so as soon as
you hear yourself complaining I want you
to stop and say okay what would I rather
have remember Law of Attraction always
let's focus on what you want not what
you don't want because we're talking
about what you don't want when you're
complaining and blaming you're focusing
on that what you don't want and you're
accelerating its expression out into the
universe with those negative feelings
and yet we'll spend a majority of our
time complaining about so many things
and usually we complain about them to
people who can't do anything about it
make a list of a hundred and one things
you want to achieve before you die now
we share this with someone last night
they said God that just seems like a
really big task I'm a single mom I don't
have any time when am I going to do that
we know that one of the things about
high achievers they all have goals only
10% of Americans set goals every year
10% and go to sales conferences people
that are the learning stuff hear it over
and over
how many 10% we also know the same 3 to
10% controlled 90% of the resources of
the world so literally without goals
your directionless you will be you see
people without goals get used by other
people who have them people that don't
have goals work for people who do and so
you want to be someone who picks up and
gets clear about what you want make a
list 101 goals I want to go to Paris I
want to you know skydive I want to
bungee cord jump I want to play the
guitar I want to learn to juggle I want
to learn to magic tricks for the kids I
want to go to the Olympics in Beijing
whatever it is make the list and you'll
see there's a lot of stuff under there
that you've kind of put down that you
want and you can have anything you want
if you want to know how to decide if a
career opportunity is a good one there
are several things you have to take into
consideration number one does it make
your heart sing the number one feedback
system that you are given at birth is
joy if you're not experiencing joy as
you as you think about doing something
and as you pursue doing it then it's off
course for you you also want to put your
rational mind to work you want it to
some due diligence ask other people
who've gone down that road before what
was it like what did they have to do
what were some of the cost of that path
what were some of the bay offs and the
benefits and really get a sense of what
it would be like to do that sometimes
you can go and do an internship or you
can work for a friend in their
restaurant just to see if you like it
because often the fantasy doesn't match
the reality and the other thing is to
simply trust yourself you know deep
inside what's true for you and if you'll
take a few minutes and go inside we call
it meditation and just ask and sit with
the question and see what kind of
feelings come up does this feel right so
do all the rational research but then
ultimately bring it back into your heart
and decide does this feel good for me
and if it makes sense up here and it
feels good then step into it just lean
into it and see what happens pursue it
no decision is forever you can always
change if it's not what you want
you're a kid you have an impulse to act
you act you want to touch the cat you
want to throw the cat out the window you
want to stick your hand into the VCR and
put peanut butter in there you do the
problem is as we're growing up we get
conditioned by our parents and our
caretakers and our siblings and our
teachers and coaches and nuns and all
these different people that come into
our life don't do that stop that's bad
you know we get slapped and told we're
not OK and so after a while when we go
to do something we're looking SoDo k if
I do this you know instead of just doing
it all my sons and my stepson and my
stepdaughter I've been great risk takers
there they're all artists once a drummer
one's a hip-hop singer one is a in high
school but he's in the school play just
had to lead mystical places sing sings
and and then my daughter's a singer and
my other son is a very athletic he's a
surfer he still boards as well and he's
always inventing games and trying out
new things always on the edge you know
always coming in with cuts and scrapes
which I love because they're out there
on the edge of their potential exploring
how they can keep pushing it and it's
not that they never get scared or they
never feel rejected and have to go
through things but they seem to rebound
very quickly
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because Naru Malkani asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I also love to know what to Jack's
ten messages had the biggest impact on
you and why what change you're going to
make in your life or business after
watching this video leave it in the
comments and I will join the discussion
also if you see some of the quotes that
people have left from Jack from these
clips and you really resonate with them
make sure to give them a thumbs up and
show some love finally want to give a
quick shout out to far bode from Paul
charge comm far bowed thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book really
means a lot to me those you watch it if
you want your chance at a shadow in a
future video make sure to grab a copy of
the book and then email in your receipt
so we can keep track thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
the other thing a friend of mine just
a book called the the fear cure and/or
the cure for fear one of those and she
talked about one of the biggest fears is
of the unknown and uncertainty of the
future but everything's uncertain you
know we're trying to create certainty in
an uncertain world and stop being afraid
of uncertainty uncertainty is what's
exciting you go to Africa on a vacation
a safari you've no idea what's going to
happen that's part of the adventure fun
that's part of the fun exactly you knew
all there's gonna be a zebra that pops
out right here this is gonna be nice
right you're boring right or if you go
river rafting you don't know where the
rapids are and how you're going to do it
and if you go surfing you don't know
exactly how the way is going to break
and all that how big it's going to be
and so that adventure is really what
life's about so we need to be excited
fear is created by imagining bad things
that haven't happened yet so fantasized
experiences appearing real everyone
always says that someone else recently
said forget everything and run but I
think that if you realize that you're
creating your own fear by imagining a
bad thing offers a recession I'll lose
my house why not go if there was a
recession I'm going to make more money
because there's going to be
opportunities and we're going to be able
to pay our house out faster Zig Ziglar
said worrying is negative goal-setting
and all you have to do is use that same
power to think and visualize to create a
positive outcome instead of a negative
and then the fear disappears let's look
at this idea of specificity for a minute
like a winter home in Hawaii very nice
but if I say I will own a two-bedroom
beachfront villa on the west coast of
Maui Hawaii by June 1st 2003 does that
sound a little more clear yeah and until
you get specific like that the creative
part of your brain won't jump in and
decide how to help you get there and
that's why a lot of people never get
their dreams because they don't make
them specific enough you got to get real
nitty-gritty break it down how much buy
when I want a better relationship with
my husband or what does that mean but if
I say I want to spend an hour a week
sitting opposite my husband talking
about real things that matter no TV on I
to eye communication that we can measure
did you do it for an hour
want to have more fun what does that
mean but what if I say I'm going to
listen to comedy albums twice a week for
a minimum of an hour you're probably
going to have more fun so make it
specific make it make it real some
people say you know I want our business
to increase well how much by whim want
the reading scores to go up in a school
how much by win until you have that
you're not going to make progress and so
many people's dreams never get completed
because they're not clear about the
specific number of how much by whim I
told you earlier in the program we said
we're going to sell a million half books
in a year and a half and that directed
our behavior recently we just said we're
going to sell a million books in one day
we had 101 bookstores involved in a book
signing I'm going to try to be in the
Guinness Book of World Record for the
largest book signing ever done now I
don't think we sold a million books
maybe we sold a couple hundred thousand
but by holding that question and trying
to figure out how to do it it moved us
toward that goal and maybe it'll take us
two years to figure out how to sell a
million books in one day but it gets the
thinking to expand out into that arena
just making sense okay so you want to
have those goals now the other thing you
want to do is break your goals down many
of you have big goals and hunger in the
world that's pretty big goal you know
have world peace achieve a certain level
of spiritual oneness with God or life
big goals when you first look at it it's
kind of overwhelming but what if we were
to break that down into little steps it
says okay I want to go to college and
get a PhD gosh I'm only a high school
student but the next step would be
finish the math class get an A in this
right for a brochure from a college get
a catalog pick one or five colleges that
I want to apply to you know just keep
breaking it down to little steps and
then figure out how to get all those
steps done and put a date by each step
and then start doing the plan someone
said if you fail to plan you're planning
to fail does that make sense yeah
absolutely
some of one of my friends said success
by the yard is hard by the inch it's a
cinch so we just break it down into
small pieces I had to I was reading the
Guinness Book of World Records because
we were thinking about being in there
and this guy set a goal to eat an entire
bicycle
tires and all now how do you do that
right well it took him 17 days but what
he did is he kept cutting the bicycle up
and then melting it down into little
swallowable pieces and he ate them I
don't know how much stayed in but he ate
right but the point being anything can
be done if you break it down small
enough make sense so don't let the
bigness of a goal overwhelm you now I
was over in Bangkok how many of you've
been to Bangkok Thailand how many of you
have seen the Golden Buddha it's one of
the three tourist attractions you always
see the Jade Buddha the Golden Buddha
and the reclining Buddha and that kind
of thing
and this Buddha is ten and a half feet
tall of solid gold the gold value alone
is about 196 million dollars that
doesn't even count the artistic and the
historical value and when my wife was
taking that picture I was over next to
the I'd say about five feet away there
was a big glass case and in that case
there was a piece of clay about a foot
wide two feet tall two feet thick and it
said that in 1953 they did not know
there was such a thing as a Golden
Buddha they were moving this large clay
Buddha from one side of Bangkok to the
other to make room for a road that was
coming through and as they picked up the
Buddha with the crane because it was
very heavy a big crack went down through
it and as the crack went down through it
the head monk got scared and he lowered
the Buddha down and he said you know
we'd better take a look at it and see if
we've done any damage to it and it
started to rain so they put a canvas
over it to keep it dry
that night the monk came out and he
shined a flashlight in to see if it was
staying dry and something reflected back
from inside the crack he said clay does
not reflect light there must be
something else in there and so the next
morning they chipped away in behind
where they wouldn't see it if there was
made a mistake and lo and behold sure
enough was this Golden Buddha and their
best theory is that three hundred years
earlier when the burmese were attacking
thai lamb the monks of this monastery
covered up the golden buddha with clay
to make it look worthless so they
wouldn't steal it they also think all
the monks were killed in
massacre and the secret died with the
monks and then they rediscovered it the
word discover means what take the cover
off of this cover something was always
in there but they took the cover off
it's having dinner with my wife that
night and she said you know Jack that
boot is like all the people in our
seminars they come in with this cover of
clay of their negative beliefs their
self-doubt their sense of guilt and
shame their beliefs that they're not
enough that they're not worthy they
don't deserve and what we really do is
we take the clay off so this golden
essence can come and be there as who
they are again they're our true identity
it's not like we put anything in it's
just that we remove the things that are
not there I think Barbara talked a
little about that earlier today so as we
go through this next hour and a half
think about and hold that metaphor that
image of the Buddha and it could be the
golden Christ the golden buddha the
Atman the source whatever you want to
call it but that's who you really are
and although we do a lot of things of
giving you more information and tools
and all of that really if you were to
stop doing the stuff that's negative as
harp said you've been defined when you
came in you were just fine and what we
did was we layered on all that stuff if
we could just start to remove that and
realize that everything you need is in
you now you have everything you need to
do everything you want to do it's just
that we learn not to trust that